hello and welcome everyone to our free
webinar on bioinformatics and data
science today we'll talk about upcoming
programs that are designed for beginners
as well as high school students and
we're going to continue to explore
bioinformatics in the context of
different types of omics data so briefly
speaking we will have two upcoming
programs these programs are going to be
focused on bioinformatics as data
science with applications to biomedical
datasets we will have a program designed
for data science and machine learning
focused on statistics and methods and we
will have a program that explains the
relationship between structural biology
and sequencing data so these two
programs are enriched with materials
that you probably already know that our
company has been offering through a
variety of different portals we're
working on preparing additional
materials including coursework as well
as technology that allows us to track
and interact with you as you go through
the various aspects of these topics that
we will cover we take and use some of
the publicly available data and
published methods in top research
journals and we offer online
certification that you can share and use
to build up your resume and develop
skills that are needed in the workforce
so in this webinar I will briefly cover
many of these topics that are focused on
two specific programs that are coming up
but in general I will also discuss some
of the aspects of these materials that
we have prepared for this program for
these upcoming programs specifically
briefly about myself my name is Ilya
Brodsky I am the CEO of pine biotech and
our company is on a mission to help
researchers to harness their data and
understand how to apply high statistical
and machine learning methods to high
throughput omics data
our company is was co-founded by dr.
Alfred Talbert dr. Lena Trotsky but we
also have a number of other team members
that are going to be closely working
with us to make this program most
possible including Julia Panov RBT
tiersky Mohit Mazumdar Joshua Kendall
and beeps viswas we have quite a lot of
experience working with a variety of
students in different settings primarily
our background is at the college and
university levels and we interact with a
lot of researchers that apply the tools
and the learning programs that we have
to understand and apply these tools to
different types of omics data so what is
onyx data onyx data is really a
collection of different types of data
including phenomics genomics epigenomics
transcriptomics metagenomics have many
different types of photonics and each
one of these different types of omics
data is used now in all types of
biomedical research and all life
sciences really so when we talk about
these applications they are important
for all steps of data generation
processing and interpretation so that's
why these programs are designed for
anyone that interacts or plans to
interact with this data in the future
for example those in the lab generating
and they need to generating data we need
to understand how we generate more and
better data about what's going on those
that understand the data and seek to
analyze that data and integrated with
other types of data and those that need
to interpret that data to make decisions
about experimental design or even about
the application in the clinic or in the
biotechnology and pharmaceutical sectors
so that's why we believe that it's
important to understand biology and that
is becoming more and more a data science
and our company is focused on developing
tools and resources to enrich fine
formatic
training and offer it at the earliest
possible level and support the growth of
bioinformatics all throughout the
professional development so that's why
we are introducing these two new
programs starting in July one is going
to be called onyx 2020 and another one
will be called genomics in the virtual
lab so these are two different programs
they do overlap so for those of you that
are thinking to join one of these
programs you can either choose one of
them or both of them if you do choose
both of them please take a note of the
timing so onyx 2020 will start on July
6th and go all throughout July 17th the
timing will be from 2:00 to 4:00 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time and the genomics
in the virtual lab will be July 13th to
24th and that will be 10:00 to 12:00
a.m. Eastern Standard Time so for those
of you that are joining us from
international locations or from other
states with other timing it's important
to take note of that as well ok one sec
ok so also please note that we have a
chat box here that you can see and we
also have a stream on YouTube so you
will be able to ask questions and we
have here EPSA and mohit that are
interacting with you so they will be
answering any questions that you might
have and also will be able to share the
specific links if you are interested in
viewing some of these program details
okay so these programs are going to be
led by highly experienced
bioinformaticians and biostatisticians
that are on our team you will see them
either directly guiding some of the
elements of the program or supporting by
providing directions and tools as well
as resources and primarily they will
include Darko Menon who is a
biostatistician and a data scientist
Julia Anant who has a PhD in
bioinformatics from Haifa University and
Monique Mazumdar who also has a PhD in
computational biology and has ample
experience in both research and working
for pharmaceutical companies we will
also have guest lectures primarily in
our program for genomics in the virtual
lab and that will be partially handled
by dr. Sona the szubin who is a
professor and a program director of
biochemistry at Georgetown University
Medical Center at in Washington DC and
she has a lot of experience teaching
both u.s. and international students and
so we're excited to have her participate
in this program and share from her
experience sharing how she developed her
skills in the onyx data space starting
from working in four PDB and now
teaching and doing research at
Georgetown University Medical Center so
first of all let me briefly introduce
these programs and the topics that they
will cover the data science onyx 2020
program will be focused on the analysis
of big data bioinformatics data
wrangling and machine learning so these
are and specific types of skills that
will that will require some elements of
conceptual understanding of what these
methods do and why they are used and
some practical and technical training
including some coding aspects of coding
that will be
in this program it will be a two-week
program in the first week we will talk
about different types of omics data sets
challenges and opportunities related to
big data we will talk about how to clean
load and process data doing exploratory
analysis and then practising some
hands-on and specific elements of
handling large and complex data sets in
the second week we will talk about
machine learning and artificial
intelligence where we will cover
unsupervised and supervised methods for
machine learning talk about model
accuracy and validation in order to
really think about designing issuing
learning processing and analysis for the
real situations that we will discuss in
the context of real project the second
program genomics in the virtual lab is
also going to be a two week program and
you can think of this program as an
introductory program that will start
from introduction to bioinformatics
discuss the relationship between protein
structure and function and focus on
multiple sequence alignment and
evolutionary analysis including analysis
of mutations and 3d structures of
proteins in this program we will have
guest lectures and different activities
and games and you will explore how
different computational tools including
different types of 3d and 3d
visualization and analysis software like
panel and chimera will be used and we
will also talk about different types of
example datasets and projects like
sickle cell anemia cystic fibrosis
Fennell kit to Nuria and code 19 so
you'll also see how in this program and
I'll talk more in detail about all of
these sessions and Emily
you learn how to access data process
that data visualize that data and try to
interpret in the relationship between
sequence and function looking at the
biological impact of those sequence
changes so in the first week we'll talk
about bioinformatics tools and data sets
including visualization and finding the
data and after we go through this week
we'll have a weekend activity during the
weekend you'll use some of the tools
that we've discussed in the sessions to
visualize specific proteins that are
important for a condition that you might
want to select and we will do this so
that you can really apply the skills
that you've learned about to a data set
of your own and then in the second week
we will kind of focus on the big data
and the availability of different types
of data sets that require both
processing and interpretation so in the
second week we will talk about
literature review and how to design your
project and how to prepare your data set
hmm how to find it how to analyze it and
how to interpret it and the outcome of
this second week is going to be to
really develop a project and present it
in front of guest judges that will
provide you with personal feedback on
your project so you'll end up by
completing this program you will end up
with a project presentation where you
will learn how to analyze the data and
explain the analysis methods that you've
used then present your analysis results
and get some specific feedback from
experienced judges that come from both
industry and research and academia and
we will also make sure that those
projects are something that you can take
with you so in your certificate of
program completion if you have prepared
and completed your project
that will be mentioned and you will get
a certificate of excellence so to
register for this first program genomics
in the virtual lab we have a
pre-registration process during the
pre-registration process and if you can
see in the chat here the link which is e
to you that T bio infocomm genomics in
the virtual lab let's say take a look at
this page really quickly so as you can
see you will find a pre-registration
page it provides a lot of information on
what will be covered in the program you
will also find the specific topics
highlighted right here and some
frequently asked questions explained
down below you will also find the
program schedule so you'll be able to
see all of the different topics and what
the sessions will include including some
of the practical activities in hands-on
sessions the registration fee is $250
but since right now we are anticipating
a lot of interest outside of the u.s.
please do reach out to us about
registration fees and the application
process by starting you can start by
filling out this information right here
and we will be reviewing this
information to determine eligibility for
the program and making sure that you
have appropriate background to join and
benefit and you can also fit it into
your time all of the sessions are going
to be recorded so you don't have to be
necessarily in all of the practical as
are in all of the theoretical lectures
but we do encourage you to participate
in most of the practical sessions that
you will see so after you submit this
form you will receive some additional
information and we will be reaching out
to you to make sure that you understand
the process registration and after
register
and completing the registration process
you will have access to this
organizational page which is designed to
support you with a forum where
discussion will take place additional
resources like courses and projects that
you can have access to and tracking of
your progress and I'll talk about this a
little bit more in the later part of
this presentation you'll also be able to
interact with some of the other
participants of the program and you will
be able to learn about them and
potentially even collaborate with them
on a project of your own okay so this is
the program called genomics in the
virtual lab and did anyone have any
specific questions about this program
that I can answer right now okay if you
have any questions please feel free to
put those in the chat again I'm
specifically going to be focused on the
chat here in zoom if you are watching
this on youtube live deep so if you
could please put it to put it in the
zoom chat okay so here's a question how
can I learn more about the topic of this
webinar
well the webinar is really introducing
these programs if you would like to
learn about the topics covered in this
program and I'm going to speak about the
second program here in a second you
should go to this link fill out the
pre-registration form and then we will
be able to send you more information if
you have some specific questions okay
what is the registration fee for Onix
2020 so I will speak about the Onix 2020
program here in a second are there any
other questions about genomics and the
virtual lab
okay okay here's another question are
the current sequencing techniques
developed or not for diagnosing rare
hereditary diseases through embryo
screening yes I believe they are
and in fact screening of those diseases
happens at least in the US and a number
of different panels have been developed
we will speak about the sequencing
technologies and the processing of that
data in the program a lot and we will
actually talk about some of those
hereditary diseases so if you're
interested in that you're welcome to
join that program okay what is the
biggest difference between the two
programs so let me so this one is
primarily focused on the relationship
between sequences and structures of
proteins and it is designed for high
school and beginner level and the topics
and the examples are chosen
appropriately let me cover some of the
topics in the second program onyx 2020
and then we will return to some of these
questions to discuss the differences
between the programs so the second
program is called onyx 2020 and it's
really focused on analysis of big data
and machine learning so in this program
we will cover things like what types of
biomedical data and data types and
formats and challenges are either now
happening or are coming up in the very
near future we'll talk about the
exploration of these types of big data
set to help us process and prepare for
analysis and understand conceptually
where is the signal and where's the
noise we'll talk about machine learning
so how to apply machine learning to Big
Data and that data could be many
different types of data but primarily
will focus on biomedical data anomic s--
and then we'll also talk about the
interpretation when we find insights in
these big data sets how do we actually
apply it to
kinds of problems so we'll talk about
that now this program is two week long
we have a number of different components
to the program the first week will focus
on different data types big data
challenges exploratory analysis and
really preparation for machine learning
and the second week we will talk about
machine learning from different methods
and settings of those methods and all
the way to interpretation and production
quality machine learning models so what
is machine learning there are two
different types of machine learning the
first one is when we asked the machine
or the algorithm to detect patterns that
could be discovered in the data right
and that's called unsupervised machine
learning the second part is supervised
machine learning when we train a model
to predict or classify a new data set
and so to understand how these different
methods apply to different types of Onix
data the first thing that we'll do is
conceptually we will utilize our t
battling for platform where a lot of
these methods are introduced and you can
apply them without any need for coding
in fact in the first part of the program
we will look at how to process and then
apply some of these statistical and
machine learning methods to the data
sets coming from gene expression
mutation variance and metagenomics so
what is the T pieman for platform the T
mindful platform allows us to package
individual scripts in a interface a user
interface that is visual and this visual
interface helps you connect the dots
using different methods organized into
logical sequences called pipelines these
pipelines are enriched with color coded
maps different methods and explanations
of those methods as well as a variety of
visual outputs that you can get directly
what's important here is that this whole
process is guided and as a result you
understand the impact of reproductions
but once you've
the conceptual connection between the
different methods and how they work on
different data sets we will actually
take you to what's happening behind the
scenes and will actually learn about
some of these methods in R and Python so
we'll learn about how the code works and
how you can modify the code and change
the settings of these algorithms to get
outputs that are designed by you that
you are looking to present or interpret
so what are the applications
first of all we'll talk about how to do
data visualization summary and
exploration including understanding of
what these different visualization
methods do and how do they really apply
to specific problems in big datasets
we'll also talk about different types of
data mining and classification methods
including decision trees hierarchical
clustering random forests support vector
machines different types of k-means
clustering and other types of clustering
linear discriminant analysis and others
so in the process of this program you
will get familiar with all of these
different methods and how they work in
what cases they are going to work and in
what cases that are not going to work
and then we have prepared a number of
practical coding tutorials that you will
be able to go through and complete in
the context of this program for example
how to do dimensionality reduction using
principal component analysis how to
identify differentially expressed genes
and understands understand what types of
pathways are down or up regulated in
gene expression data how to do
clustering and how to find organization
of those clusters and understand how to
interpret it from a biomedical or
biological standpoint and then in what
cases do we actually use support vector
machines linear discriminant analysis or
random forests what types of features do
they provide us with that we can use for
what kinds of problems and so in the
context of these practicing exercises
you will actually go through a structure
across
this is going to be organized by both
our code and Python code so you can
choose either one or try to do both and
we have a system that will guide you
from understanding the problem to
learning the code to modifying the
outputs modifying algorithm settings and
then applying it to it is says that we
give you or trying on a data set that
you yourself want to apply it to as you
go through that process you will have a
series of tasks that you need to
complete and every task that you
complete you will be able to get some
points for so that is a process that
will build up your profile and help you
achieve the objectives of this data
science program we will talk about how
these different methods are actually
applied to biomedical research problems
for example we'll look at Diagnostics in
cancer biology we will talk about tissue
and single-cell sequencing we will also
talk about metagenomics and infection
caused by different types of pathogens
where do these projects and datasets
come from we actually take them from
publications from top research journals
that highlight important aspects of
machine learning in application to real
datasets and real problems that
represent clinical problems so when we
talk about that type of clinical problem
or a pharmaceutical or biotechnology
problem we actually will explain how the
different types of datasets and
different types of applications differ
as you go from basic research to
translational research to actual
application in the clinic and so we'll
talk about these different projects in
terms of application for clinical like
patient stratification disease
Diagnostics mechanism of disease onset
and progression and also pharmaceutical
and biotech challenges like biomarker
discovery or target discovery drug
reversing and requisitioning so we'll
talk about a lot of these applications
as we
go through the different examples that
we have prepared the second program
Comics 2020 again we have a
pre-registration link so you can see
that in the chat but let's go to this
pre-registration page and I'll show you
what other information is available here
so this page right here will tell you
some specific details and you can read
about all of these topics and see some
of the topics that I am covering in this
webinar but you'll also see a little bit
more detail here including how to set up
some of these tools on your computer and
what exactly are you going to be able to
learn in these different sessions that
we have prepared so again once you have
learned about these topics you're
interested to apply to this program you
can sign up and once you sign up we will
look at that data we will see where
you're from and what is your level and
what is your background
if you have any questions we'll be able
to answer those questions and we'll also
share with you any other resources if
you have a specific interest or topic
that you are pursuing ok so any
questions about this program first and
then I'll talk about the comparison
between these two different programs ok
so I don't have a powerful PC so how
will I use the biopython
program ok great question let me
actually show you why we have designed
some of these technologies around being
able to process and analyze data on the
cloud so two specific technologies that
I want to cover today one as I mentioned
all of these different methods are
including on our powerful T bio info
multi-omics pro processing platform
and here you will see I'll just show you
a couple of examples how essentially
what your role is is to prepare a
workflow you will be guided on what
these specific methods do and how they
connect together you will see how your
choice of methods will provide different
types of outputs and those different
types of outputs could then be prepared
for what's called downstream analysis so
here you can see me building an RNA seek
pipeline the rna-seq pipeline will
generate a table of expression and after
I have that table of expression I can do
differential gene expression analysis so
once I click on end you don't need any
computational resources on your PC or
your laptop to be able to look at the
outputs okay the second example is
actually the coding environment this
coding environment is again going to be
guided you can select whether to choose
R or Python so for example here you see
principal component analysis and you see
all of the code in R you will also get a
console and you can run this code this
code runs in the browser so it does
utilize some of the resources on your
laptop or on your computer but you can
see that what it provides us with is
some standardized outputs and some of
those outputs are going to also be
incorporated into the grading process so
how do you actually take this from here
onto your computer you can just change
this right here you can modify the
script you can actually follow the
process of learning the code how to
modify the visual outputs how to modify
the algorithm settings and at the end
save whatever modified script you have
to run on your own computer what to do
if you don't have a powerful computer
you can either try this and see how it
works right and use it on smaller data
sets
or we also provide the same capability
that is going to happen without any kind
of you know utilization of your own
resources or all of it happening in the
cloud and actually that is one of the
topics that we will discuss what are
some of these challenges with the actual
big datasets right because they do
require a lot of computational power to
process and really get it to a place
where you can interpret it okay any
other questions about the our mix 2020
program okay let's talk about the two
different programs in terms of fees and
outcomes and then I will actually return
to complete some of the things that I
still didn't have a chance to finish
so the Onix 2020 both of these programs
are essentially two-week programs the
two weeks are going to include some Q&A
sessions they're going to include some
hands-on sessions they're going to
provide you with curated examples and a
lot of additional materials that you can
utilize both of them are essentially 15
days or you know 14 sessions essentially
but you do get a lot of other materials
and longer account access to all of the
materials even after the program is
completed so you will have it for 30
days Onix 2020 is $150 genomics in the
lab is 250 dollars both of these
programs are led by experienced faculty
and you get individual certification
yeah for the courses that you complete
you will have a lot of guided material
in these courses about different types
of omics data and about different
methods and a lot of people actually
utilize some of these to build up their
portfolio and build up their profile for
example here you can see some weeks
sharing some of these on LinkedIn and
ultimately standing out from the crowd
right so you will be able to complete
the coursework get a certificate of
completion from the full program and
also work on an independent project if
you have that independent project let me
actually cover some of these examples
and explain how these materials work
okay so as I mentioned we have been
working for a long time with researchers
academic centers universities and
colleges to prepare a lot of these
materials this is the first time that we
were offering these materials on a wide
scale to people that even do not have a
degree and are potentially in high
school but looking forward to getting
involved in these kinds of topics but
we've prepared a collection of materials
that include introductory materials on
bioinformatics genomics transcriptomics
epigenetics metagenomics and machine
learning all of these materials are
personalized so you will be able to go
through the different materials that we
have and build up your profile you build
up your profile by completing specific
assignments doing the specific tasks
that you're assigned and ultimately we
can track all of the progress and help
answer and personally address any
questions that you might have at the end
of the program we also have a leader
board and on this leader board we
highlight those that achieved top
positions on this leader board inside a
specific program many of the elements of
the programs are going to be designed
around this platform on this platform as
I showed you you can interactively go
through the process and understand what
each method does without any coding
background without knowing a lot about
the different methods but really working
through the projects to understand what
these different things do you will also
see interactive visual outputs and those
outputs will help you understand
the methods do in the context of a
specific project for example you'll be
looking at the relationship between
sequence and structure and another side
of this is for those of you that are
interested in coding or potentially have
some experience already in coding we
will have this environment where you
will be able to go through the scripts
understand how the square roots work
understand how to modify the scripts and
then apply them to datasets of your own
to apply them to datasets of your own we
will actually guide you on how to read
the literature to understand what types
of data is used in a specific research
project to then understand what types of
methods were applied in the discussed
article and then to combine this data
and this method with your understanding
of what else you have learned in the
program what other data sets you can
find and develop a novel and independent
project so we also will provide you with
a lot of examples where you can start
focusing on specific types of biomedical
or research projects for example we have
a series of projects that will be made
available that include epigenomic
analysis of asthma data different viral
and infectious diseases changes in the
transcriptome different cancer related
projects even agricultural and
neuroscience projects so ultimately
going through some of these examples
you'll be able to develop a project of
your own when you develop that project
of your own we have examples of college
level students as well as even high
school students so here you can see and
maybe beeps say you can share the link
to the blog that talks about Hanna Davis
who did one of these programs and was
able to complete a series of materials
and develop a project of her own related
to
related to diabetes so some of these
projects sorry all of these projects are
taken from publications they are
organized in a structured way and then
students have been reviewing those
projects and using them to actually
develop independent projects and get
feedback from their peers and from
experts now we are taking this program
online but you can still develop a
research project that will eventually
culminate in a poster presentation which
could be supplemented by a video
presentation of your team reviewing the
project analysis steps and the outcomes
of that of that research study so those
are common features between the programs
and as I mentioned the differences
between those different price different
types of focuses one is more focused on
the relationship between sequence and
structure and how to understand and work
with those types of datasets the second
one is more focused on specific types of
machine learning and data science
methods with some element of coding so
the first program will not have coding
the second one will have coding the
first one will have some other tools
like chimera and Pinal and will have
different types of projects in the
second one it is going to be more
focused on the basic data types and
specific types of methods in machine
learning okay so the question will it
help in Kimo taxonomy and phylogenetics
the first program is more related to
phylogenetic analysis and taxonomy will
talk about how to do multiple sequence
alignment how to understand
relationships between protein sequences
or nucleotide sequences things like that
so that would be more the genomics lab
program okay so I already went through
this information and let's see if you
have
any other questions that I can answer
right now okay if there are no other
questions I did want to highlight that
some of the previous participants of our
programs started off without any
background and we're able to apply some
of these advanced methods in a very
short time that's one of the critical
aspects of the program is that actually
the time it takes from learning about
these methods to actually applying them
to a data set of your own and doing that
analysis will be instead of years it
will actually take you just a few weeks
we are not promising that you know every
single person will come out with an
independent completed and analyzed
project but we do have repeat
participants participants that have
joined multiple types of programs and
supplemented those programs with
additional online resources that we
provide on the platform and help
actually put those skills to use in the
context of a narrowly focused program we
also have a number of people that come
from biology background without any back
any background in data science or coding
so people that just come from the lab
and you learn about bioinformatics in
for the first time but we also have a
number of participants that have
previously joined that are you know
postdoctoral and faculty level that are
able to benefit from some of the
materials and some of the examples that
we cover in these programs I do want to
mention that even for those of you that
potentially have you know faculty and
teaching experience some of the
participants that we've had have found
these courses informative as well and we
really try to in
great a lot of the aspects of the
feedback throughout the program to
improve the materials as we go along
and we realized that the programs are
short they do not provide sometimes
enough depth and enough time to simply
complete a project during that specific
program so that's why first we allow you
to have longer time with access to tools
resources datasets and even getting
feedback from the program organizers and
trainers but we also offer a specific
program that is focused on research
internship and research fellowship so
that is another opportunity that I just
wanted to highlight for this session
these programs are training programs the
training programs will walk you through
a specific syllabus or a curriculum as a
result of going through that curriculum
you will acquire specific skills you
probably will develop a project idea
find the data set and understand how to
analyze it if you don't have enough time
typically a pro a project that requires
you know that you want to take all the
way to publication level or a poster a
serious poster at you know some kind of
a research conference that might take
between three and six months so we
designed this research internship to
specifically work for those that join
some of these training programs and then
would like to continue to work on their
independent project applying the
cloud-based tools that we have getting
support in regular sessions where they
interact with others and have access to
all of the different programs sessions
right so if you are thinking okay maybe
I want to participate in both of these
programs you can do that if you're going
to work on an independent project by
simply joining the research internship
and then you can actually participate in
many of the sessions that are designed
to train you or to guide you in your
project preparation process so again the
research internship
blink is also available let's take a
look at that link really quickly on the
pre-registration for this summer
internship so again this is a rolling
enrollment so you there's not
necessarily a starting date we kicked
off the program in June but we have
people that joined even before that what
you will get here is access to all of
our materials all of our tools it will
be completely online and remote it is a
paid and internship so you have to pay
for access to some of these programs and
tools but once you join again once you
fill out this form
we are happy to continue and send you
additional information on how you can
get the most out of this opportunity ok
so are there any other questions that I
can answer at this time related to these
upcoming programs or related to the
internship program if you're interested
in participating in an independent
research project ok so I encourage all
of you to stay in touch with us you
probably have seen some of our social
media posts and we have a lot of free
resources available as well
if you would like to join and check the
quality of the materials and make sure
that this is the type of course that you
will benefit from I encourage you to
sign up to sign up let me just briefly
walk you through we have a number of
different portals designed around
specific audiences so the first portal
that we will use during the programs
that I highlighted today is called
science coach it's done in collaboration
with an organization that deals with
students in schools that do high-level
research
and here on this site you can see that I
am logged in so once you create your
profile you you can change you know
obviously your you will set your
password you will join a specific course
and that will start appearing on your
profile so if you register for free you
can already start accessing some of the
materials and that includes introduction
to bioinformatics and and some other
introductory courses as you see some
additional courses that you are
interested in you can either purchase
them individually or you can get access
to all of these courses in the context
of these programs that I highlighted
after you do that you will start seeing
points accumulating on your profile and
you'll also see how these points
actually compare to some of the other
participants of a program which is what
we use them for but also help us track
all of your activity and that activity
includes the different pipelines that
you run the different codes that you try
and we can then address any of the
issues that happen around those
pipelines so really it's more than just
a portal with courses it is actually a
portal designed to build up a community
so this community is specific for high
school students interested in research
and we are now just recently expanding
this and for those types of participants
we have another site that is very
similar and that site is our main portal
for all of our online participants and
we have many programs that run from this
main portal which is called edu that T -
bio tech info and here you can see some
of the participants especially those
that have been highlighted here in our
blog we regularly highlight some of the
participants of previous programs and we
post all kinds of announcements rouler
to the programs that we have so I did
want to highlight this recent blog post
by one of our participants who's a
bioinformatician at Atlas program
company that does genetic testing and
you can see from his perspective why he
decided to joining the Amish logic
training as opposed to as you know
they're you know many available courses
that you can take and so you can read a
little bit about his background and what
he has been able to achieve including
how he has used his experience in this
program to design a program of his own
and he shares even here some of his
notes from some of the sessions so you
can see here how he has been
participating in some of these
discussions that we had during the
session so you can get a sense for what
that what those sessions cover and how
the different assignments work how we
review the different elements here
specifically you can see about : 18 and
then how obviously you can what type of
takeaways you would have from this
program so I encourage all of you to
take a look at some of those reasons
again I believe that we are putting in a
lot of effort into making these programs
effective and not just post out there
are some materials that you know you can
find anywhere online okay so any other
questions about these programs that'd be
happy to answer them now
yeah he'll give it a couple more minutes
beeps if you have any questions that are
on YouTube please share those with me as
well if there are no other questions
thank you for joining today and I will
be looking forward to interacting with
you during the program I will be also
personally present and many of those
okay Esther is asking is it PC required
or can the courses be managed on an iPad
yes all of the coursework can be managed
on an iPad in fact even some of the
materials on the platform you can access
on your iPad I do not think that we've
done sufficient testing on an iPad
because obviously to practice some of
these assignments you would have to
download and upload different data sets
and I know that's a little bit
complicated when you have an iPad so if
you want to try you know we're happy to
maybe work with you and see how it works
but you can definitely try the free
course for now on introduction to
bioinformatics see how that works on an
iPad
you know I'll show you here briefly
introduction to bioinformatics is a
course that talks about big data and
different sequencing technologies and
different types of applications of
bioinformatics in different domains you
can see that a lot of the coursework
will be videos and some of the
introductory specifically in the
introductory courses are focused on
materials to help you get started
understand the different applications
and practice you know evaluating what
you have learned as you go through the
more advanced courses they start giving
you assignments and those are graded
assignments but they will be you know
related to downloading some datasets
doing some modifications
those datasets than uploading the
results or things like that so that's
the issue regarding just having iPad
access
okay if there are no more questions and
I am going to look forward to
interacting with you again during the
programs if you decide to join and if
not I still encourage you to take some
of the free materials related to
bioinformatics and different types of
omics data sets as you go through those
we are going to continue and send you
upcoming program information if you are
going to be interested in some of the
other programs that we will have coming
up either in August or coming up in the
fall we have a lot of new material that
is coming out and we are excited about
how that material will help prepare the
next generation of politicians so again
thank you for joining today and we will
be putting the recording from this
webinar on our YouTube channel the
youtube channel also includes a lot of
the materials that you will find related
to bioinformatics and to different
aspects of what we what we do on a
regular basis so obviously those of you
that are on YouTube you already have the
channel but please take a look at some
of those materials there as well thank
you very much and have a great rest of
your day
you